what kind of mad fart well those that
loud but also sounded far away hi
everybody so welcome in the closet I'm
Jen that's Nikki today we're gonna talk
a little bit about personal style
specifically how's your style might
change after you come out and talk about
this I have my friend Ashley here Ashley
you want to come on crawl in through the
closet side door yes I've always seen it
online but I didn't realize how cramped
it was until I was here know it's
cramped it's but I still like this I
don't know okay hi Jen how are you I'm
good
tell me a little bit about yourself what
are your problems what's your favorite
thing to eat my name is Ashley my
pronouns are she her well for a second I
forgot what pronouns where I was like
[ __ ] they are she her and my favorite
thing to eat is soup I love a good soup
what yeah everyone is weirded out by mac
if I could only one thing it would be
soup there's so many kinds there's stews
their soups there's like different
flavors soup yeah I like soup in short
I'm gay what am i I'm queer okay okay
that's cool after I came out as queer I
went like every way on the style
spectrum I was like super masculine
super feminine like chapstick lipstick I
was in a sorority before and so like
everything was super feminine and I
always remember feeling like really
awkward about what I was wearing and my
clothes and that kind of stuff and so
after I came out I was like oh good I
can finally be myself but it was funny
cuz I was like I don't know how to be
gay and so I like bought a bunch of like
snap backs and like button ups and vans
and stuff and like that didn't feel
completely easy wardrobe I thought
Nikki's exact wardrobe I did the easiest
thing that I could do was just copy
clothing and then I was like exposed to
more and different types of queer women
I was like oh they kind of all just have
their own style so like I didn't have to
do it one particular way did you cut
your hair after you came out I did I cut
my hair during the same year I started
like really fully dating and like just
like being out did you feel more
comfortable afterward or were you a
little scared like oh man now everyone
knows I did it like cuz I was I wanted
the convenience of like not having long
hair when I was younger there was so
much of like trying to like hide people
from knowing I was gay yeah that like
when I cut my hair I was like Oh am i
letting them win feeling like yourself
yeah being able to get to a place where
you can feel like yourself in your
clothes and also be comfortable with
everyone seeing that you are yourself
being a queer person kind of complicates
that but I also think it's kind of cool
you get to like paint your own palette
and decide what makes you comfortable
it's hard to sit in this closet like for
my back it's let's talk about back
issues in the closet yeah y'all know
this game it's called spin the bottle we
asked the question we spin the bottle
and whoever it lands on has to answer it
honestly
have you ever farted during sex here we
go oh me I feel like yeah I farted but
it's never been noticed one time the
girl I was dating at the time farted and
I felt so bad because I didn't
immediately identify it as a fart
anyways like I jumped and I was like
what was that like I started really
offended if I'd known it was a fart I
wouldn't have said yeah I felt like a
bookshelf fell I liked precarious down
there cuz depending on where you are you
might be really close to someone's lower
parts oh yeah yeah like between like
bedsheets in your face what's the
grossest thing you've ever done
Nikki I don't know I will like regularly
pick boogers oh that's disgusting Nikki
get them anyway thanks for coming in
this is great be yourselves a little
queer angels dead don't open up don't
don't drink Joe okay oh it didn't do
anything it's so immediately smells just
like pure orange that expired two years
ago yeah let's leave the classic right
we're
thanks for being gay and nice okay cut
[Music]